jambières toi qui as fait le miraculé un
drôle de paroissien ça te fait quoi te
retrouver dans un confessionnal
c'est un lieu que je connais bien parce
que quand j'étais petit j'allais me
confesser maintenant je me confesse que
beaucoup je crois que c'est la première
fois que je me confesse depuis 50 ans tu
crois que tu es un mécréant
anat et plus tôt alors on va passer aux
sept péchés capitaux est ce que tu pèses
par orgueil non là je crois pas non je
suis plutôt trop pain blanc remarque
c'est une façon de drogués aussi par
avarice
oui je suis radin ça tout le monde le
sait mais c'est parce que j'ai pas eu de
fric au départ parce que tu sais que les
réalisateurs c'est sait pas très bien
casque et c'est pour ça on est peut-être
la luxure par contre tu as beaucoup de
lennon oui pas mal n'ont ils pas mal
mais ça s'arrête pas encore tous ces
championnats disais que quand il avait
90 ans il est toujours retenu enfin
maintenant les partouzes du cinéma avec
le sida c'est un peu fini non au oui
c'est fini ce n'est pas une gêne à
l'époque ça c'est terminé maintenant
tout le monde a peur c'était quelle
époque la grande époque
ah c'était 48 s'est-elle existentiel il
jean paul sartre les bonnes femmes qui
se foutent et par la fenêtre dans le
quartier saint-germain la travée c'était
le début une fille sortait de chez elle
à les coucher comme ça chez l'un chez
l'autre ça a commencé comme ça c'est
sartre camus tout ça qui ont mené sur
cette impulsion
maintenant c'est un peu fini puisque le
sida c'est le ventre tu as dit si on
devait mettre bout à bout les bassins de
toutes les femmes que j'ai sauté
ça ferait 200 m tu es fier de dire des
trucs pareils
oh non c'est de la vantardise est ce que
tu feras le divorce j'ai fait un film en
66 justement parce que j'arrivais pas
divorcer j'ai mis dix ans pour divorcer
alors pietro germi a fait divorce à
l'italienne ou tuer sa femme s'ils
pouvaient pas s'en sortir autrement puis
moi j'ai fait quelque chose qui
s'appelait les compagnons marguerite
avec claude rich cho lui il efface est
carrément les actes de naissance comme
ça les gens étaient divorcés
automatiquement le suicide
on peut se suicider tout en continuant à
vivre il faut faire quoi faire ce qu'on
a envie de faire je suppose quand on en
a marre de tout il faut faire n'importe
quoi mais parce que ça sert à rien ça
fait de la peine aux autres est-ce que
tu est favorable à la peine de mort on a
honte hu et trois mecs par an dans la
région du nord en général et pauvre mec
alors pour trois mecs inspirant et la
peine de mort c'est vraiment on n'a
jamais condamné à mort ceux qui
méritaient de l'être alors donc
finalement c'est que des lampistes qui
on a exécuté pour la plupart même pour
les assassins d'enfants ça j'aime pas
j'aime pas les assassins d'enfants ça
ça peut être que faudrait les mettre
dans un cas un peu spécial particulier
je sais pas il faudrait lui parce qu'il
faudrait en faire mais la mort donnée la
mort je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a le
droit de le faire et tu favorable au
droit de vote pour les immigrés oui tout
le monde a le droit de voter ça sert à
rien de toute façon tu crois en dieu je
suis je t'ai dit que j'étais athée et
mais je crois à quelque chose mais je
voudrais bien savoir comment on a été
créée pourquoi je te parle en ce moment
je voudrais bien savoir qui c'est qui
m'a mis là ceci dit ce mystère je ne
l'est pas je suis incapable de découvrir
de le déceler le percer à jour alors
jean merdé quoi je me dis quand je serai
cannes et qu'est ce que je vais devenir
est-ce que tu as les tabous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de linda hardy tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux